le che du sport voilà comment était
surnommé diego maradona par fidel castro
lui-même ancien compagnon de route du
révolutionnaire argentin
au delà de son statut de joueur de
légende l'ancien génial numéro 10 était
également connu pour sa dimension
politique et ses choix symbolique et ce
alors qu'il était à l'apogée de sa
carrière professionnelle en 1984 il
quitte le prestigieux fc barcelone pour
rejoindre la modeste équipe de naples
l'enfant des bidonvilles de la banlieue
de buenos aires emmène le club sur le
toit de l'italie et de l'europe
après la fin de sa carrière el pibe de
oro concrétise ses engagements par le
biais de plusieurs déclarations et
rencontres fortes en 2016 il rend un
hommage appuyé à fidel castro dont il
était très proche
comme un clin d'oeil du destin le lider
maximo décède également à 25 novembre
c'est une journée horrible on m'a
annoncé la mort de celui qui a été le
plus grand sans aucun doute
fidel castro est mort je suis
terriblement triste parce qu'il était
pour moi comme un second père maradona a
toujours assumé son adhésion aux idées
du socialisme latino américains après
son soutien inconditionnel à hugo chavez
il n'hésite pas à prendre la défense de
son successeur nicholas maduro tout en
égratignant au passage le président
américain donald trump
je veux dédier cette victoire à nicholas
maduro et à tout le venezuela qui
souffre actuellement à cause des shérifs
du monde que sont les yankees qui
pensent pouvoir nous mener ce tyran
qu'ils ont comme président ne nous
achètera pas l'une des dernières prises
de positions fortes de diego maradona
concerne le conflit israélo palestinien
après avoir fustigé à plusieurs reprises
le comportement de l'état hébreu il
rencontre mahmoud abbas en 2018
à l'occasion de la coupe du monde en
russie depuis l'annnonce de la mort de
celui qui est considéré comme un demi
dieu dans son pays
les hommages se multiplient dans le
monde entier preuve de son statut
exceptionnel
l'argentine a décrété trois jours de
deuil national leo messi
souvent présenté comme le successeur de
diego maradona a salué sa mémoire par
ces mots il nous quitte mais ne
disparaît pas parce que diego est
éternel
à